Isn't it ironic that all these men these men are watching Destiny
lose in court and they're still writing him? Dude,
sorry. That was the time. Some weird weirdo. Of course. Of course
he's losing in court. That white dick hallucinated
see that isn't even there. Holy [__] Huh? Without
their consent. Yes or no? Just say don't give me no. Yes or no?
Um I don't know. I guess you just have to see it to know what
I was talking about. Because of because it got really intense
and spicy or because of length or both. Yeah, I mean, yeah, I
mean both. Yeah, both. It uh and uh Ethan talked about it on
stream today. He's like telling he's like set up he wants me
to come on at some point. So, it's like and that and then that
invites that invites like a bro I mean like I already have like
a small little cadre of like lefty accounts on Twitter that just
speaking of your boy your Vanguard boys Josiah. I don't know
if you know this. Oh, they talk so much about us bro. They are.
I know they used to. They went after me. They went after lip
ring. What did you do? What did you say? Um, you'd have to ask
them. I mean, like one of them made fun of me for having a lip
ring at one point when it gets our nose ring. But like, no, they
like you should watch they they reacted to us talking to Crystal
Balm. Uh, and you should watch the video cuz they Sorry, what?
They're just mad about it generally. They they these people I'm
tell like these people hate me. They've hated me for a long time
cuz I insist on like like just being super practical and pragmatic.
Like that's like my guiding principle and they just hate that.
And so yeah, they I I didn't realize like there was like new
anti-Hutch content. Um but yeah, we should invite them on is
what I'm saying. I would like to bring our boys on. Yeah. Are
you friends with the Vanguard? We've collabed. Uh so Josiah's
collab with them. I think I've definitely collabed with them.
Um we had a good conversation. I don't think they've collabed
with Econo Boy, but you know, if they're going against my boy
Hutch, I mean, shit's going to get
Refive and learn, guys. This is awesome. No, guys, we were all
friends, right? We should all be friends. I'm uh I really like
Zach and Gavin from the band. I thought their attacks on you
were uh like over the lip ring. Like that was like [__]
up and petty. But I mean everything else not well well I haven't
heard the other criticism. I don't know. They called me for example
they call me a they call me a destiny sick of ant which is pretty
unbelievable. I mean I realize that's a very difficult topic.
I mean they got him there. That's facts. Sorry but just the the
aversion of eyes from cameras just a kind of boy a kind of boy
is banning up. Okay. But I feel like we got some eyes. They call
me a destiny sick fan which is pretty unbelievable. I mean I
realize that's a very difficult topic. But like it's unbelievable.
Like it's a completely like baseless.
It's pretty baseless. That's baseless. Is it bro? They're not
they they just stop. They just all stop. I think you by any stretch
could you call that a baseless claim that he's a Destiny sick
offend? That's not baseless by any stretch. You you could say
you don't agree with it. You think that's untrue? That's unfair.
It's not baseless. That's just not true. Well, he also I thought
he just came out and said that he uh like he doesn't want anything
to do with Destin yourself. I thought he just might have been
in response to it, right? Well, he did a he did No, it was a
chat message. I don't know when this took place. He was like
I don't know. It's still kind of mey mouthed like he made he
made a big mistake. No, this guy's like a crazy freak.
Yeah, I think um I don't know. At least Hutch didn't really collab
like closely with him. Feel like the rest of them I don't know.
It's whatever. Bro, I saw like a pixie tweet today where she
just tweeted that she was depressed and like all of the most
liked comments are just from random DJers that uh are just like,
"Well, I guess that's because you you whoever convinced you to
sue Destiny was really not looking out for you or something because
you're it's just like,
you disavow." Yeah, sure. Disavow. Sure.
wait. What's a disavow here? What do we Frenzy freeze? Who do
you think is a dis what do we think is a disavow here? Not that
I like I don't I don't need everybody to disavow. Wait, he said,
but yeah, I don't want to work with him. The doors might be open
in the future, but I would never close a door on anyone, even
like Dr. Disrespect or something like that. Um, and then he he
but he also described it as a big mistake. It's like, no, no,
it wasn't it wasn't a mistake. I mean, it's not just one thing
either. Based on based on a lot of the what do you call the testimony
coming out seems like it was a pretty
meticulous panel of people that I assume are big problems with
bad and panada because of his doxing and crazy behavior. So,
I would hope they would carry over that principle to their friends.
Probably not. Somehow I don't think they would. Probably not.
No. Don't you understand though that like if you are like referenced
enough by You're like actually you're like actually responsible
for everything they did and that means you've basically swatted
people. So really you being doxed is like the bare minimum they
can do in response which is like right from
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's just how it be.
Twice that he's not obligated to take his reputation on destiny.
Sure.
I think like it
I'm sorry but our relevant didn't wait to see the facts. He literally
just was like this is what appears to have happened. If this
is what happened then like I would need to see contrition. I'd
need to see like a distinct pattern change. I need to see like
an actual like admitting of wrongdoing and and like a a deliberate
effort to change over years to re-engage with this person. It
was like it was like the easiest thing to come up with like on
the fly and all relevant said it instantly without like and he
he even said like he even conditioned it. He's like well if if
this really did happen then yeah sure rile's linking this this
must be Hutch's
dis thing. Um see this
one of you guys mentioned destiny a minute ago. The dramatic
dream the issue is that one of our strongest warriors is not
being attacked. The the issue is one of our strongest warriors
is not being attacked and you and I both know destiny is needed
more than ever. Listen, I I cannot associate with Destiny. Can't
do it. I am not obligated to put my own reputation at risk. You
know, he up like heed up. And I'm not saying he needs to disappear
from the face of the earth. People Well, that's hot. The earth
people up. People up big. People make huge mistakes. People make
worse mistakes. You know, I'm not saying he needs to go away
forever. No, Zezy. Pisco's career is far less dependent on Destiny
than like Rei. Really was like trying to get back into streaming
at the time and the bump would have been incredibly helpful to
him. Uh Pisco was kind of building stuff up and now like Pisco
is way beyond doesn't need the help anymore. But I I'm I'm not
obligated to put my reputation at risk because because of decisions
that he made. You know,
ABBA from ABBA and Preach did a video about it and he pretty
much summed up my exact feelings. Like he straight he said the
exact same thing that I was feeling like Destiny up. I I can't
be associated with him. He knows he
he made a he made a a very big mistake and I and I you know I've
been I didn't look at the uh what do you call it exact same thing
that I was feeling like Destiny [__] up I was because
of optics not because he's terrible great set of morals I can't
be associated with him he knows he [__] up what's
up Chinese agent how's it going he made a he made a a very big
mistake and I and I you know and I think he undermined his own
sort of like position doing that.
I again it's weird. It's just like whatever. You don't really
need to police people I guess but it's like not one mistake.
It's literally it's literally like he has admitted to having
sent the videos to it just shows their no it's not it's policing.
It just shows their thinking because they know all the they know
this guy's like a totaling insane freak. They may know what to
think like oh he's not he's not like a malicious person but he
does do a lot of bad things but they know he does all these bad
things. It's just this is the one thing they know they can't
sweep. This is the one thing they know they'll get hassled over
by a bunch of people, a bunch of podcasts, a bunch of chatters
for all the time. So, this is the thing they disavow over, but
they're not making statements on the other stuff cuz the other
conduct they would they would let slide even if they would criticize
it from other people because that's they are hacks. I would just
say that like with with like the the leaks from Rose, you have
like multiple women who have come out and said this was non-consentual.
I did not consent to this. They've made the same claim as Pixie.
They're just not suing him. And so when they say one mistake
to me, it's like what they're doing is they're trying to hedge
and say like as long as this lawsuit goes away, we're fine. Like
we'll go back talking to him, right? Like yeah, but that lawsuit
one, he's already admitted to the conduct. So like morally, he
is culpable for the thing you're disassociating with him for.
Like morally, it's not even a question. He's literally admitted
to it. He he signed a statement saying as much, right? So like
already you're disavowing is like a spineless living this guy's
like pop a gut level to be honest. So uh probably I just don't
watch like I don't watch any of his content. I just got no idea
what this guy's
opinion I've had a really bad impression from the few things
I have seen. Yeah, that's fair. So but to me it's like they're
basically saying as long as this goes away I will uh like I'm
fine with him or whatever. You're addicted to his clout. Even
I even think think back, right? The first time I ever saw Hutch
was in Destiny content and it was um Have you ever seen that
old debate where like Hutch is beingounded by some chatter about
talking to Destiny? Yep. Yeah. The fact that he was even like
cowtowing or entertaining that sort of freaking out is like such
a It just shows your personality. It just shows that you are
like um spineless amorphous. I don't think these people are drama
or really caught up in the loop. I just I totally I don't see
how that's possible, Joe Mama. Like I don't how many people Why
would you be friends with Destiny and not be somebody who would
go like, "Oh, I should look into that." Like I think if you're
already friends with that kind of political person, you're going
to look into like that to begin with, right? There's something
beyond just politics. It's not like you're going to hang out
with like, I don't know, Hassan or uh what's his name? You're
not like trying to follow around Sam Harris or anything like
that. You're following around somebody who's got like a specific
brand. This isn't drama. I mean, you could say that I to begin
with. Also, when you're disavowing somebody for the sake of your
brand and your optics, I feel like again, you should probably
incumbent on you to look into it. Just don't think he wants to
smoke from DG like you and Queman have. I mean, eh, I don't think
that's the case, but maybe. I think what it is is you can say,
"Oh, well, this was really bad and I disavow it." And then shut
the up and DJers will still watch your stuff, right? So long
as you're not consistently calling Destiny like a a piece of
[__] DJs will watch your stuff and not really complain.
Like I I like uh I like Lon Box. Lonox watched some content piece
of mine today. Oh, he watched he watched me argue with that skitso
guy. That really skitso guy. I also thought it was hilarious
how he immediately knew I was trying to like troll that guy into
anti-Semitic conspiracy theories. He was like, "Is it is that
what he's trying to do right now?" I couldn't believe he caught
that. Who did you debate? It was some guy that was like debating
rally and he came on my stream and he was talking about like
Christian Zionist and a bunch of crazyit and then um I eventually
I was like talking him through it and I was like walking him
through his own I was just questioning his own thought process
like bouncing stuff back off of him and he was talking about
something with like um like the tribal leadership of like the
Taliban and a bunch of the other like clans and tribes from the
Middle East and I was just like wait so like you know it's like
a deliberate effort of Israel to like keep those people bulcanized
Right. I like started trying to like poke him into being like
America's owned by Israel, but he he wouldn't do it. He's like,
"I don't believe that. That's totally that's anti-semitic conspiracy
theory and I think you're trying to get me on something and I
don't want to do that." And I was like, "Ah, you I also typed
in chat that that was what I was about to do." So, I think he
might have had chat up. It was too bad. It was really funny though.
It was a good time. Yeah. I I thought it was funny that Lonerbox
watched it. Dude, I think um I don't know. We'll see what happens
with Pixie stuff. There's like gonna be we're like a week away
from a whole bunch of stuff dropping in that case, right? Like
there's two deadlines, the third and the fourth. And I don't
keep up with it that closely, but yeah. Well, I mean, I read
the last set of docs and I always keep I just mark the dates
on the calendar when they're like due dates or whatever cuz then
it pops up on like the day they're going to since everybody seems
to wait until the due date to respond.
So, we'll see. What is it? It's like the preliminary injunction
I think they're having on the 4th. Well, I think sorry I said
due dates, but uh I think the preliminary injunction hearing
is on the 4th. We'll see how a whole bunch of stuff goes then.
I guess we'll see like if um if like threatening people and constantly
talking people like makes a difference. I guess we'll see in
the preliminary injunction hearing. I don't know how much it'll
matter. Maybe it doesn't matter at all. Desty seems to think
it doesn't matter at all. Pixie team thinks seems to think it
matters.
Be interesting to know.
Oh, hold on. One of these was supposed to be from Destiny's sub
or something.
Tread lightly. Rules are still in effect until this arc is over.
Why we call it an arc? The past arc.
How often has Desi been right about what matters in this case?
I don't know. Like
Let's see. Pretty sure he's maintained this position since January.
Don't know why this is news now, especially when there isn't
any resolution
yet. Am
I allowed to ask questions or is that ban worthy till the case
is over?
All right.
Check the replies in that screenshot I sent. Wait, what screenshot
did you
I didn't see the screenshot, bro. Send it on Discord. Oh, you
did send it on Discord. I just had this DM open.
Oh, let me see this.
Cowardly as a longtime DJ. Why was this never used for any of
the other drama drama we've had in the last five plus years?
That would take over the subreddit and wouldn't resolve anything.
It's only bad. It takes over the subreddit because it makes Destiny
look bad as it as it should. Assan would do the same. Destiny
should stand trial by the Daliban and should be made to look
at post after post day after day. Muslims got over their prophet
being a lolly lover. Are you afraid the Taliban will get over
this? Jesus Christ,
that's uh strange. What the is a very weird comment? There's
a comment in this thread about Hutch.
It was basically it's a response to the uh the moderator or something,
I think. Hold on.
Is it a response? The mod definitely responds. Or no, Hobbit
follower. Hold on. This is the response from the mod. Enjoy the
perma banan. I'm sick of all of you talking as if we need to
sit by and let the subread turn into some snark where everyone
just has to watch endless litigation of a situation over and
over again. As a longtime DJ, why was this never used for any
of the other drama we've had in the last 5 plus years? We literally
made it where you couldn't mention Anavir, Mr. Girl, Lavan Bosch,
and countless others. Why couldn't you mention Anavoir, Mr. Girl,
and Lav? What was that? possibly for the same reason as this
because those situations if they were discussed too much might
end up making Destiny look bad
eventually.
Yeah. Hold on. I'm looking for where this was. Was there like
third response? I don't see it in the third response, but maybe
I'm just blind's case cuz he was outsourcing it to Kiwi Farms,
I guess. Explicitly. Explicitly. So anyway, uh you just didn't
give a we banned the entire IP conflict for months last year.
Yes, he should sign by the Taliban. It should make B need to
look at post after post after day. This is the cringiest line
of this whole thing. I'm going to be honest here, dude. I don't
think he cares what you think about the situation. The Taliban
lau you will talk about like about other people like Yeah, you're
talking like that about your guy now. Why is that problem? Well,
you have to censor opinion from people just to listen. Do you
know that Hassan like banned anybody who mentions Nukaku in his
chat? It's soed up and crazy.
Actually, it's so
That's That's just disgusting. Muslims got over their profit
being a lolly lover. Are you afraid the Dalban won't get over
this? Most people are over it and don't need to litigate something
that's been out in the open for four months. Hopefully you get
over it if you're honestly still as mad over my moderation choices.
Yeah, I suspect I know this this might seem crazy to you. I suspect
Forthought might have walked over this, but we'll never know
cuz I think he kind of walked before this. But I I actually suspect
that Forethought might have been like, "You know what? I'm I'm
good. I'm out. Is that crazy? You think that's nuts?
I have no idea. I don't know. I suspect he would have for some
reason. He hates. I didn't see cake around at all. I'm pretty
sure cake quit his job with Destiny. Is Five Thought Fourth?
Because I see the Reddit user Five is still a Destiny. I have
no idea. I doubt it. Oh, Scribbel's a moderator here now. Crazy.
I'm surprised Scribbel is a fan. I should I should message this
guy and ask him to come on. You ever watch this guy? Quan, you
ever like see this guy? He hopped on Indian guy. Oh, that's sad.
Would have thought would have thought this guy was smarter. Remember
that guy was insane. Yeah, he was big on spiritual stuff. He
was big on doing the right thing, on leaning like lead leading
like a clean life, leading like a actually Yeah. No, if you knew
who that guy was. I had DMs with him and stuff. If you knew who
that guy was, that's actually kind of crazy to think that he's
a mod and he's like active in the subreddit right now. That's
crazy. This situation give us a real close look at who everyone
actually is. It's kind of true.
Yeah, I saw Mr. Girls physics arc. Boring. Well, he is Indian.
Is he not? He hates women. Well, I don't think he's supposed
to. He does love Aya for some reason. Used to think was smart.
Imagine my disappointment. Joji, was that based on watching Noto
Aerodite's content or is that based on just like vaguely hearing
her on occasion in some places? You ever watch any of her content
long form? I'm not even taking shots. I just feel like that's
the general that's generally like people Yeah. Okay. vaguely
hearing her. Yeah, that seems to be the general idea is like
people like she seems pretty smart and then they like listen
to something long form and they're like, "Oh, never mind."
Space Ghost, you should link me that to be honest with you.
I'd look at that. There were apparently like Darius Murk moments
tonight. Were there funny things going on there or what? I'd
probably check that out real quick before I go.
Did she Cameron was pretending to be black? No.
Was awesome.
Apparently Mkin I've never seen anything quite as transparent
as Darius like immediately trying to uh date Murk.
GG. He just didn't have like he just needed a W after the whole
Zena thing. He's just like, "Yeah, I guess we're dating now."
It's pretty
funny. Jesus.
no. It's like an African American man with No.
Curtis Jackson. Curtis Jackson. Any Okay. If you're going to
put the feet of a 6'4 woman in your mouth, you are kind of gay.
Those got to be some big stompers. Okay. just like this is this
is just to give you this guy this guy will not stop imitating
Destiny. Okay, this is up.
All right, I have too many jokes for this. This is this is just
to give you guys a representation. Okay, he like had the Just
think about it. Okay, couple somebody who comes on this street.
This is going to be violent. Yeah, this is this is basically
what they missed out on. Okay, Kelly. Kelly, this is basically
what you missed out on, Kelly. Okay. Your whole [__]
Yes. He tickles.
He like he
like always this guy.
Yo, he's like watching. She's like a weirdo, bro.
She has
17 her colon.
Particles are floating into your mouth right now. Okay. Put peanut
butter on her toes and suck it. Break them up. This is maybe
the most degenerate stream I've ever seen in my entire life.
[__] What's Nick up to? Well, you strike me as like
a calculated. You could think a dog escaping. First of all, they
can bite somebody. They can sue us. We can lose a dog. Stuff
can happen. Not going to troll. I think there's like a bunch
of like deliberate trolls. I have to switch to something else.
In Nick's chat, they're just like encouraging him, telling him
he's like awesome. They're like, "Nick, don't even do this content.
Go do like date. Go do like uh RZ content." Okay. Go to the club,
do RZ content and stuff.
Yeah, that'd be
Anyway, this this thread was up for a while and then I think
it got nuked, taken out.
But I hate this framing, too. Understood. But also, what reputation?
manga establishment probably laugh at this stuff so much that
neither Tate, Alex Jones, and even little President took a hit
to their reputation among their base. It's all tiring being on
this side. Just make content and when society is genuinely disgusted,
then turf them out.
Okay, hold on. The follow-up to this was annoying. On the other
hand, it's just so easy to not jeopardize your shrooming career
by with BPD chicks. We'll probably get banned for typing this
common sense comment, though. Okay, hold on. He didn't get because
he was involved with BBD chicks. He got for sharing tapes with
the consent of the other people in the tapes. Kind of hugely
different.
I don't think Pixie has BPD. I just I don't think actually I
don't think Molina has BPD. I What is this?
Be back like at a regular time tomorrow. Wait one second. Hold
on. I am going to watch this.
Hold on.
All right. Are we kissing some weirdass weirdoit? Of course the
internet. I want to give special thanks to this person. I want
to give special thank you. My hand in the
Who are you?
He literally made a YouTube goodbye video of him leaving the
[__] leave the internet. No one gives a [__]
Just like if I left the uh Is this talking
She's not talking about outdoor boys right now, is she? There's
no way that she's talking about outdoor boys right now. [__]
outdoor boys. I I'm I'm throw hands right now. Okay, nobody gives
a about us people. Like, what are you talking about? Jesus, M.
You're overthinking it. He's taking up space in your head. All
right, I'll stop thinking about it. Um MC, by the way, left my
Discord and told me I was a terrible human being for allowing
Parseek in my Discord. Is she going to hold Darius to the same
bar? Is Darius having Parseek in his discord? Is that enough
for him to be a terrible person or is it just me when I have
Parse in my Discord? Got it. Anyway, moving on. very curious
to know that he had explicit sexual
encounter deeply.
Wait, is this time advertise on twitch.com
redact.dev tomclansy
sucks.com redact.dev Dev advertise on twitch.com
Hey Jamie, pull up that clip of Murk saying, "Yeah, I told him
he could come and Oh, this is not going to go well." But I was
joking. Anyway, yeah, space. We bet you care about
weirdo. And we're going to Listen, I'm not talking about that
kid, but we're talking about Isn't it ironic that all these men
these men are watching Destiny lo and they're still writing him?
Dude,
Sorry, that was the time. Some weird weirdo. Of course. Of course
he's losing in court. That white
dude [__] that isn't even there. Holy [__]
Huh? According to people, did he or did he not share nudes at
people without their consent? Yes or no? Just say don't give
me no. Yes or no? There he is.
She's raping him. Let's go. Don't you hug or no? Did he not?
Yo, yes or no. Did he do that? Okay, he did. And of course, you
think you of course they're all weirdos, dude. People on the
internet are weird, dude. Weirdos.
I think they already has a daddy. Oh my god. I'm not listening
to you. DG dick dick suck [__] dick sucking dick
sucking gross guys. That's what GGG stands for and I'm over it.
that parse kid hit different and he was still in grade school
when
brother there uh
sucking gross guys that's what d sucking gross guys listen she
she's declared it okay can't go back no it's sucking did sucking
is hyphenated okay
word yeah mer graduated lingo
people like I'm over it antiway way. Isn't it weird too how people
being I am not sure you understand what revenge is, which is
what he is being sued for, but just sharing videos.
That's legally with me. You're obsessed. You're obsessed. Hey,
what [__] Darius, go run her a bath. She deserves
it. You want to run her a bath?
Okay. Now is not a good time. I don't think we should take a
bath. I mean, you should take a bath. No. Oh, I [__]
about making you more money. Oh, we could I don't know. But what
did you sell? What did you give up for that? My likeness. What
did you give up for that? Your dignity. Your manhood. My dignity
is right here. Yeah, buddy. My dignity is right here. Whatever
crumbs you got left. Standing 6' tall. You're 5'8. You're 5'8.
Okay. Just That's funny though cuz she's definitely I Have they
done a sidebyside? Have they done a height comparison? Cuz that's
funny as she is very tall. She is like 6'2 unironically. You're
5'8. You're 5'8. But uh Oh man, she must be asking about Zena
doing only fancy. You're 5'8" with my beautiful dog. You're literally
5'8.
Literally lying. You're lit. You want to stand next to me? You're
going to get a blast from the past. You love to see it. Wait,
I take my dog outside. No, no, no, no. You can't stop. Stop,
dude. I hate the woman touching me physically and forcing me
to do stuff gives me trauma. Stop. I think you Okay, so next
you want me to beat the you so then you do what I ask. No, I
just I want to I want to set my boundaries. Oh, now you're now
you're setting boundaries. You don't set boundaries so a woman
can't put her hands on you and leave you with a black eye, but
you want to get proved that you're 5'8 and suddenly you have
boundaries. Got it. Oh, she literally asked him for a height
comparison just now and he refused. I see. Got it.
Yeah, it happens. Put some pants on. I have pants on.
The allegations. What allegations? That you're 5'8. No, but I'm
taller than you. You're not. And I have more dignity. Mhm. You
have a black eye. You're not going to have a black eye. I don't
keep talking slick to me. I'll talk to you. However, I want to
talk to you. Keep talking slick to me. Ain't going to go be pretty.
Yikes. Rackets. I want to talk to you. We still have a kiss right
now. Yeah, but I'm worried if like I kiss you. It'll ruin like
future relationships. Dude, you literally had me put my toes
in your mouth last night. I don't care about that. I don't want
to be like, "Yo, I kiss you." And then people are like, "Ew,
you kissed Darius. I'm good off that." No one would ever say
that. People like literally fly out of country to see me.
Most of the guys that I talk to are off the internet anyway.
So maybe they'll never see this. Off the internet or on the internet?
Whenever I eat. You ate in this house? Yeah, maybe we skip the
Zena stuff. I might have skipped it. Looking around,